for more on this I'm joined Now by New
York Republican congresswoman Nicole
motakis thanks for being with us
congresswoman um want to know what you
make of this news now that there's going
to be a reciprocal trip a Mexican
delegation's going to head here to
Washington to meet with President Biden
at the White House this month sometime
in the next handful of weeks to continue
this conversation that they started uh
at the beginning of this week about the
Border crisis what do you hope to see
come out of that meeting at the White
House look I think this is all show all
talk uh we don't need to uh consult with
the Mexican Government what we need to
do is get our president to re the
executive orders that he himself put in
place um look we we can certainly work
with other countries but the onus is on
the United States government to secure
its borders if we cannot secure our own
borders what does that say about our
country I mean this is very dangerous
they just said another 80,000 godaa
aways this last quarter that's on top of
the what 1.7 million individuals that
have entered our country undetected but
are estimated to be here uh that's not
the people that are coming to the Border
claiming Asylum those are people who are
purposely sneaking in why are they
purposely sneaking in well we know Iran
is trying to send individuals here to
commit Terror they caught somebody on
the terror watch list from Iran just the
other day at the northern border we know
that the drug traffickers are killing
Americans with fentanyl that is
streaming over the Border um and our
president does nothing about it it is so
outrageous that the president of the
United States would put the drug cartels
ahead of the safety of his own American
citizens look President Biden resent the
executive orders Chuck Schumer pass our
border Security Act which we passed in
May this can be resolved easily if we
just had the will from the Democrats to
work with us to do it um somebody who
actually agrees with you that the onus
is on the United States is the president
of Mexico himself coming out of that
meeting uh with secretary blinkin in
mayorcas in Mexico City earlier in the
week the Mexican side of the delegation
made very clear that they see this
border crisis as a uniquely and
specifically American problem they put
out all kinds of statements saying that
you know they would like to quote help
as much as they can um seems like he
agrees with your takee here look look
the bottom line here is that this is all
for show he's trying to show the
American people that you know he's doing
something but he's doing nothing this is
a self-created crisis by Joe Biden and
now that he's entering an election year
he's concerned because the V majority of
Americans including Democrats are saying
that immigration uh illegal immigration
is out of control the migrant crisis
he's losing people in cities like New
York City and Chicago this is becoming a
major political problem for the
Democrats and so they're doing a dog and
pony show and reality is they just need
to reinstate the policies of the
previous administration or Chuck Schumer
could pass the bill we passed in May and
this would be resolved and we do believe
in legal immigration I'm the daughter of
immigrants we want to see people who
want to come and contribute to this
country but they need to do so the
proper way not paying the drug cartels
thousands of dollars to being smuggled
here the crisis is very much so becoming
a political liability for the president
he's getting criticism from both sides
of the aisle take a listen to New York's
mayor Eric Adams who puts the blame on
Republican Governors like Governor
Abbott but also specifically on the
Biden Administration take a listen this
is a national problem this has only been
exagerated by Governor Abbott's cruel
inhumane politics and that requires
additional National Solutions the
federal government must take
responsibility and lead on this
humanitarian crisis the federal
government there being code word for
President
Biden you look you have 10 million
people who've entered our country via
the southern border uh they have to go
somewhere so this is turning every city
in America into a border City
particularly the ones like New York City
where you have Mayors who are
incentivize people to come over uh
that's what he's doing he's offering
Free Housing free health care free food
free laundry service uh free college
education you name it you can get it in
New York City and that is why more
individuals are coming here yet we have
a backlog now for those people who have
come legally and have applied and are
waiting now it's a 10year wait in court
that is so unfair that those individuals
are being pushed to the back my office
has helped over a hundred of those
individuals navigate the red tape and
become citizens but so many are being
told that their court dates are now much
later because this President is
incentivizing or rewarding the people
who pay the drug cartels to come to the
southern border and giving them court
dates priority that is so wrong and our
mayor is only further incentivizing this
by um providing all these free services
while cutting by the way services for
the taxpayers of New York right he's he
wants to put a freeze on hiring police
and school safety officers he's cutting
across the board city services you can't
go to a library on a Sunday anymore
they're not doing garbage pickups in the
Parks regularly I mean this is what the
Democrats are prioritizing they're
prioritizing illegal immigrants over
taxpaying citizens uh Congressman we got
to leave it there but thanks for taking
time with us on this New Year's Eve day
we wish you the best and happy New Year
have a happy New Year thank you I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis